The breaking news.
Lawyers for former President
Donald Trump
have been seen going
into the Department of justice.
You write in the rember
that Trump's attorneys
requested a meeting
with Attorney General Merrick Garland
last month
in connection
with the special counsel's investigation
of classified documents at Mar a Lago.
CNN's Evan
Perez joins us now
with the very latest on what is going on.
Evan, is this meeting still taking place?
It is still taking place,
as far as we can tell.
John,
we have not seen the Trump attorneys
leave the building.
There's only one way
in and out for visitors.
So we're sitting there
waiting to see what they might say
when they when they exit.
But, look,
this is a meeting that the Trump lawyers
requested just in
just a couple of weeks ago now.
They were asking to meet
with the attorney general,
Merrick Garland.
No sign
that Merrick Garland
is actually meeting with them
at this moment.
Neither.
Any sign that that
that they're meeting
with the deputy attorney general,
Lisa Monaco,
the way these things work,
you know,
certainly for the Justice Department,
because they're trying
to keep this investigation
in the hands of
Jack Smith,
the special counsel
is, you know,
they might try to accommodate
a meeting
with somebody who is a career
official here at the Justice Department
who can at least hear
these complaints that they have.
What the Trump
attorneys wrote in their letter
is that they believe that there's
been prosecutorial misconduct
that has gone on in this investigation.
They didn't specify
what exactly
that prosecutorial misconduct,
just that the former president
is being treated like,
unlike anyone
in the history of the presidency.
And so that's partly what they
their beef is
and that's what they want to try
to bring across in this meeting today.
Now, again,
we don't know the specifics of that
alleged misconduct
that they're making
that they're claiming.
But we do know that one of the things
they're very unhappy about
is the fact that Jack Smith
and the prosecutors
have obtained
a trove of information, including client
attorney client
privilege material, material
that normally is shielded
from investigator
But they got that
because a judge determined
that there was an exception
under the crime fraud
exception
that allows prosecutors
to obtain that kind of evidence.
So again, we don't know exactly what
how long this meeting is going to go,
who exactly they're meeting with.
But we know that what they want
is they want to delay
some claims
about the way
this investigation has been ongoing John.
And just have
one more question on the timing here,
because I know you and others
are reporting
that the grand jury that has been hearing
testimony about this is back
meeting again now
for the first time in some time.
So what does that tell you?
Right exactly?
I think
that the context, the crucial timing,
I think, is very important here.
All signs
indicate that this is an investigation
in its closing stages.
And that could mean a number of things.
That could mean that
the grand jury,
which hasn't been seen at the courthouse
since early May, is coming back
to get some wrap up witnesses
to get some additional testimony.
It could be
that you bring back a grand jury
that hasn't met in weeks.
To bring an indictment.
So there's a number of possibilities
that this grand jury
could be coming back for.
We do not know.
Obviously, Jack
Smith is holding his cards
very close to the vest.
But I think that's one of the reasons
why this meeting is so important,
certainly from the Trump perspective,
because if they want to try
to get to somebody
inside this building to say
that there should be a pause,
that there should
something should be stopped,
now is the time to do that, John.
All right,
Evan Perez,
we're gonna let you get back to reporting
if you learn anything new
about this meeting.
Get back to us right away.
In the meantime, we're going to speak
to CNN legal analyst Laura Coates.
Counselor.
Great to see you.
First, a general question.
In a meeting like this,
which is not unheard of
when you have
someone who is being investigated
their attorneys asked to meet
with prosecutors,
what's the nature of the conversation
behind closed doors?
Well, first
of all, the power dynamic
you have to keep in mind here, John,
it's the prosecutors
who have all of the power here.
They know what testimony has come
in, what has not.
They know if there are any gaps
in their evidentiary burden
looking towards perhaps a prosecution.
They know what witnesses there have been.
They know who is cooperating.
They know who is not.
And they've largely
probably been able to outline
what are the potential statutes
that could be implicated by the conduct
that they are now investigating.
And so
when they hold the bulk of those cards,
this meeting is not
just a magnanimous gesture.
I don't want to make that
to make that claim.
But what it is, is somebody
who has the intention as the prosecutor
to be closed mouth,
to not be as forthcoming
as they could be.
Say if they were in an open
courtroom or trial,
because the other side
is every incentive to then
go out and talk and try to spin.
And that has already been the track
record here.
The idea of misconduct
is a huge allegation,
a huge claim to level
against any prosecutor.
But certainly
the Department of Justice, obviously,
knowing that they have gone
to great lengths to Jack Smith
to have the impropriety
that was hinted at by Trump and his team
to be distanced
from the attorney general,
Merrick Garland,
so that no more thing to keep in mind
here is the power dynamic.
And as Evan rightly pointed out,
there's a little bit of kudos
that ought to be given
to the entire process here,
because grand juries
are supposed to be secret.
We're supposed to be
a little bit in the dark here, John.
We're supposed to be wondering
because that presents more fairness
for the defendant or a potential target.
If we know everything
and the court of public opinion
can undermine the ability
to get a fair trial,
a fair jury impaneled,
if that were ever to get there,
based on everything that we do know
and as you correctly, note,
that's limited what we know.
Where do you see things right now?
Well, this
is, first
of all,
when you're talking about the attorneys
wanting to come in.
We have the reporting from last week,
our excellent
reporting from our own colleagues
about the nature of documents
that may have been viewed,
whether they were disclosed
or wanting to be disclosed to anyone.
The idea of his own statements
before our town hall with Kaitlan Collins
on his intention
to retain documents and believing
he had every right to do so.
And then the report
reports of tapes potentially
that show
that he did not believe
that he had the ability
to show them whenever he wanted to.
We're waiting on all the culmination
of that reporting
based on that, the length of time
and, of course,
the January
six prosecution, which, of course, is
part of what Jack Smith is looking at.
We are really nearing towards
the end of an investigation cycle.
Keep in mind, as though as well as this,
we are,
you know,
over 500 days away
from the presidential election.
But internally,
the Department of Justice
has its eyes on the novelty of this
entire investigation
against a former president
and one who
wants to have the RNC nomination, again,
a purported frontrunner
in that very race.
And so they already know
there are time constraints.
And when they can
launch investigations,
launch prosecutions,
because they do not want to be seen
as interfering with an election.
And so the timeline is already
a little bit strong for that very reason.
But I suspect, given the fact
that they have all this information
and if intent was all
they were waiting for,
the reporting has come in
and seemed to draw a very clear line
that they know what that is.
Laura Coates, such important context.
Thank you for laying all that out
so clearly. For us.
I appreciate it, Sarah.
All right.
Thanks, John.
Kristen Holmes is going to be joining us
now in Washington, D.C.
She's been following this case
and obviously talking
with those surrounding Donald Trump.
Have you heard anything from them since?
We have found out that they are
their lawyers are
now meeting with the DOJ.
Well,
sir, we haven't had an
official comment from the Trump campaign.
However, I did
speak to two advisers
who gave me some background information
on what exactly
this is going to look like,
what exactly they are trying to ask for.
You heard Evan mention
this idea that they are characterizing
this as prosecutorial misconduct.
I am told by one adviser
that they plan
to provide
specific examples of overreach now.
When I asked
what those specific examples were,
there was no detail
given there,
but something to keep in mind
that they believe
that they have
some kind of evidence here.
The other thing
that I am
told by another adviser
that they are planning to argue
is that the best thing to do
is to close this case before the election
and essentially
alleging that
if not, this could lead
to election interference.
That is something that we have heard
from former President Trump.
And it gives you somewhat of a preview
into what he might say
if he loses the primary.
As I heard from these advisers
they believe that this
Republican primary field
will be completely set
by the end of the week
or at least almost set
and that the election has begun.
And that's something that they plan
to argue again.
That this could interfere
with that election
and gives you
a little bit of insight
into where the brains are right now.
Yeah, well, as this goes further
and gets closer
and closer to the primaries,
they're going to make that argument.
But have they given you any indication
about what exactly
they are talking to the DOJ about?
You said just prosecutorial
misconduct, overreach, but any specifics?
Not even one.
Not even one specific.
And I have asked routinely
what exactly
they believe was prosecutorial misconduct
as well as details
into what they are saying was overreach,
what kind of examples that they have.
Again, I have not heard back on
anything specific
as to what they believe
that this overreach was.
Well, I'm sure we're going to hear
from someone in this case
after this meeting.
We appreciate your time, Kristen
Holmes, and your reporting.